would you rather leave a date with a hot  chick for 10 minutes to take a [ __ ] or  hold it in and hope for the best i would  rather [ __ ] on my date i'd leave her for  10 minutes i'd leave her for t dude how  about this one time you ready for this  one time is that the comedy sell in new  york city i s beautiful girl took her on  a date to the comedy seller i'm like hey  just wait up here i got to go downstairs  do my set 15 minutes set easy breezy i  come up she's gone i was like i saw the  waitress i was like where's the girls  with just with she goes oh she left with  uh aziz i'm sorry i was like wow this  [ __ ]  took my day dude and then i [ __ ] went  home and i jerked off to masters of none  yeah i talked to him about it he you  know claims he doesn't know he doesn't  yeah he's like oh i don't even know man  i'm sorry i was just doing something  you know